I'm a superfood we will be taking a few
days away from the tour just to have
some time it's flown by this year's been
I think four she and I both probably the
craziest of our lives but really nice to
kind of have that centering grounding
feeling with each other on top of
touring with his brothers and starring
in Midway nick has already started
shooting the voice he's the newest coach
joining Kelly Blake and John next season
it was a bizarre moment when I went up
to sat in my chair and I looked to my
left and right and that's a cool cool
feeling to be a part of that company
after I took that that moment to embrace
this this new chapter in my life
and looked at all of them said I'm gonna
take you down another job for Nick his
latest collaboration with John Varvatos
JV x NJ Silver Edition fragrance Nick
was in my studio quite a bit and always
spritzing himself his goal in life was
the vest melanin and shows us how I
apply my JV NJ silver I go for kind of
one of these or those center of the
chest but it is more sprays on it it's
like six total
[Music]